allora
un giorno come ha detto io sono un
ingegnere quindi per cercare di tediarvi
il meno possibile
dando il meno possibile di tecnologia di
quella tecnologia che potrebbe risultare
noiosa
io ho pensato di convertire il mio
speech a sua insaputa di parlare di
filosofia
una filosofia che ho chiamato ixem che
il nome del laboratorio che ho cofondato
con alcuni collaboratori nel 2004 presso
il politecnico di torino e un
laboratorio che avevo una mission molto
semplice e molto ben definita che era
quella di provare a realizzare delle
infrastrutture delle reti che potessero
permettermi di portare internet la
connettività ma quella vera quella con
le capacità adeguate imposti che
potevamo giudicare quasi improbabili
isole montagne deserti foreste era un
obiettivo abbastanza ambizioso anzi
direi parecchio ambizioso e l'altra cosa
che avremmo voluto fare di lavorare con
la tecnologia a supporto della
sostenibilità questo diciamo per andare
contro quell asserzione che abbiamo
giustamente correttamente fatto
all'inizio non sempre la tecnologia è
qualcosa che incentiva la disuguaglianza
qualche volta potrebbe anche invece
favorire proprio una maggiore
ridistribuzione di di che cosa
fondamentalmente di banda larga
questo era il nostro primo obiettivo
quando cominciamo a lavorare nel 2005 il
nostro primo campo di lavoro manco a
farlo apposta sul comune dove io vivo
per la savoia
l'ottanta per cento dei comuni italiani
tra il 2005 e il 2006 andavano ancora
con il doppino 56k sembra una vita fa
sembra una cosa impossibile però era una
situazione che durava nel tempo e in
alcuni casi durata ancora fino al 2011
allora quello che decidemmo di fare per
venire in soccorso il mio comune fu di
provare a realizzare una cosa
assolutamente sperimentale andammo a
prendere delle apparecchiature
totalmente obsolete all'interno dei
nostri laboratori che ormai non possiamo
più per nulla stavano a prendere muffa
le trasformano in trasmettitori e per
dimostrare che con questo si riusciva a
portare una certa banda larga sul
territorio
pensate realizzando dei ponti che da
torino arrivavano fino a quel comune a
60 chilometri di distanza dove ha prima
uno scopo
che andava 2 megabit 2 megabit oggi non
è nulla allora era un enormità
nel giro di qualche settimana si
alternarono 70 diverse persone che
abitano in quel comune che a 1450
abitanti la metà dei quali over 70 che
andavano a utilizzare la panchina anzi
ne dovessero mettere un'altra per
collegarsi a internet per tramite di
quel semplice o spot la cosa funzionava
e ci prendemmo un po gusto per cui
l'anno successivo decidemmo di fare
delle cose leggermente ma solo
leggermente più professionali per inter
collegare alcune scuole ben 13 su un
territorio molto più grande quello che è
rappresentato lì nella zona del
monferrato monferrato cavallo tra
diciamo il primo lembo di pianura padana
e il monferrato dove avevamo delle
situazioni di grande criticità dal punto
di vista dell'accesso internet
ebbene in quella zona otterremo un
risultato straordinario perché
nonostante le maestre non fossero
particolarmente avvezzi all'utilizzo del
computer
riuscimmo realizzare le nostre reti a
mantenerle anche grazie al fatto che gli
stessi studenti bambini perché stiamo
parlando di scuole elementari
insegnavano alle maestre come utilizzare
la tecnologia allora da quello ci venne
in mente un'idea se noi riusciamo a fare
tecnologie a basso costo e riusciamo a
portare delle bande adeguate la banda
era cresciuta in quel caso riusciamo a
portare fino a 8 mega bit e riusciamo
anche a gestirla per tramite di una
professionalità che non è esattamente un
laureato allora perché non proviamo a
portarla ad esempio in africa e quindi
cominciamo a riempire quel tassello
africa deserto eccetera
questo era un po l'idea però ci dissero
no la vostra tecnologia va bene avere la
sua voce ci siete voi appena portate
fuori magari in un posto un po critico
non funziona più allora per dimostrare
che poteva funzionare decidemmo di
salire sul monte rosa 4.556 metri sul
livello del mare e decidemmo di
realizzare da a partire dal monte rosa
collegandoci con il politecnico a torino
una rete che come vedete in quel grafico
che sta alle mie spalle doveva
praticamente arrivare a
collegare punti diversi a cavallo
dell'arco alpino il più lontano di
questo il monte cimone nell'appennino
300 quasi 300 chilometri dal monte rosa
alla realizzazione fu fatto ovviamente
sempre con le nostre tecniche quindi
cercano di risparmiare il più possibile
proprio sulla manifattura dei materiali
quella foto che vedete sulla destra e il
momento in cui io sto incerottato un
trasmettitore per farlo funzionare con
della carta stagnola rubata al cuoco di
un rifugio stria co rifugio stria cody
vallunga a 2.800 metri di altezza e vi
immagino la faccia che fece il cuoco
quando gli ruba la carta stagnola con
cui a loop sviluppare in ulster e per
riuscire a far funzionare un
trasmettitore la cosa funzionò diciamo
che portammo antenne quello sono io
su quella seggiovia che è l'unico modo
era per risparmiare ovviamente sui costi
anche di trasporto
prendemmo qualche rischio nel montare le
nostre antenne quella foto che vedete
sulla sinistra e momenti in cui feci la
mia videoconferenza dal monte rosa al
monte cimone e non è proprio esattamente
canonicamente una postazione di
laboratorio ma quello fu il primo
momento in cui realizziamo questa
connessione avevamo circa tra monterosi
mostre cimone e li avevamo estremizzato
tutto ma avevamo circa trenta megabit
questo nel momento in cui balla sulla
cima del monte rosa nella capanna
margherita montiamo il nostro access
point su spot wifi lo è ancora adesso
più alto d europa il disastro fu che
quella sera tutti gli alpinisti erano lì
a collegarsi al computer anziché andare
a vedere il panorama fuori ma tant'è
questo è il destino di chi porta
tecnologia e anche di vederla poi
utilizzata magari in modo non proprio
opportuno allora grazie a quelle
credenziali riuscimmo ad ottenere un
progetto ci lavora ma portiamo la
bandina amazzonia
nel 2008 andiamo nella regione di porto
francisco e orellana e li inter
collegano la capitale di quella regione
con un piccolo paese un piccolo
villaggio che era ubicato veramente nel
mezzo della foresta non strade
condizioni di percorrenza e quindi era
davvero un lavoro che ci appaga va e che
entrava in quel tassello più della
montagna anche se la montagna l'aveva
ho già tassellata potevamo fare la
foresta il momento in cui realizziamo
una delle nostre strutture con la
collaborazione la gente locale è
esattamente come nel caso dei bambini
della scuola elementare vicino a casa
nostra andammo a insegnare agli
autoctoni persone che non erano laureate
come si potevano mantenere i nostri
apparati la una delle cose che
assolutamente mi piace far vedere e che
fu un po il motivo di orgoglio di quelle
realizzazione sul fatto che innanzitutto
ci lavorarono e questo per dimostrare
che non era necessaria la presenza di un
esperto ci lavorarono solo i miei
studenti
la seconda è che arrivano a realizzare
delle situazioni come questa una scuola
di uno di quei paesi nel paese dai
humala trasformammo in una scossa così
allora questo avveniva nel 2008 nel 2010
e vi parlo sull'applauso solo perché
sennò quell affare che continuano a
scorrere poi dopo allora nel 2010 e
facciamo un passo indietro
tornammo a verrua savoia perché averlo
savoy era successa una cosa particolare
noi avevamo tenuto questo spot nel 2005
lo molliamo e lo devo ad una
azienda privata che era subentrata e si
era ritrovata praticamente il lavoro già
quasi fatto il problema che si realizzò
un digitale di weil in digital divide
perché quell azienda si limitò a dare
copertura nei dintorni dello spot è il
paese molto più complesso lo vedete quei
puntini bianchi rappresentano le case e
fortemente disomogeneo nel
urbanizzazione direi che
l'organizzazione praticamente e su tutto
il territorio abbiamo cinque valli
abbiamo un fiume il po abbiamo una
situazione che è molto complessa di
conseguenza decidemmo di riprenderci il
territorio
la rete la realizziamo noi visto che i
provider non la volevano realizzare
realizzammo 5 punti di accesso quelli
indicati con quelle frecce gialle
l'inter collegano con i nostri sistemi
ovviamente cercando di fare tutto in
laboratorio per far vedere che si
potevano fare delle cose particolari
mettemmo anche un centro proprio di
ridistribuzione un centro operativo vero
all'interno del municipio e quelle che
vi sto facendo vedere sono tre esempi di
realizzazioni realizzate con il
contributo e l'aiuto delle persone del
territorio
bene quali fu il risultato tutti mi
dissero massiva realizza quella rete
distribuisci pure la banda domestica ma
nessuno si fiderà di un laboratorio del
politecnico degli accademici e giusto
gli accademici sono inaffidabili per
definizione però la reti che fanno gli
accademici magari invece no allora
quello che successe tra il 2010 e il
2014 e che il numero degli utilizzatori
famiglie perché poi davamo la banda in
casa crebbe fino a 260 unità e al di là
di questa che è provocatorio perché
questo è il dato che riguardava nel 2014
più fortunato di tutti è quella banda lì
non ce l'avevano tutti averlo savoia
comunque mediamente andavano a 13
megabit in download e 13 in upload
e una cosa che nel 2010 a torino non
c'era se non per pochi eletti e per
pochi fortunati
questo fu il risultato ma la cosa
sensazionale fu che questo che era un
lavoro scientifico e di natura
sperimentale ottenne una collaborazione
da parte di tutti i cittadini
a causa di una grossa nevicata ci fu la
fila di volontari per andare a ripulire
i pannelli solari che avete visto prima
per andare a mantenere il servizio in
efficienza fino ad arrivare alla
situazione in cui qualcuno coccolava il
proprio pannello per collegarsi alla
rete in quel modo lì e fino a che
qualcuno addirittura per cercare di
scimmiottare si cercò di costruirsi le
antenne da soli gli spiegammo che però
non poteva funzionare allora grazie di
nuovo a tutte quelle credenziali che
ottenemmo con quel nuovo progetto e noi
continuiamo a rimbalzare d'averla al
mondo
proponemmo la realizzazione di una rete
assolutamente simile ma su una scala un
po più grande e nelle isole comore
nell'oceano indiano una situazione
disastrosa ancora peggio di quella che
ci trovammo prima nella foresta
amazzonica il tipo di abitazioni dei più
fortunati è rappresentato lì le
condizioni di accesso alle strade pure
nella foto di destra mettendo insieme un
team abbastanza anomalo e 2 autoctoni un
arabo e io e un tesista cubano ste
rimanemmo lì per tre mesi e mezzo più o
meno nel 2012 realizzammo questa rete
una rete che permetteva queste persone
che si trovavano a situazioni come
questa e quel telefono pubblico nel
mezzo della giungla gettoni con nessuno
che avevi gettoni per farlo funzionare
ad una situazione come questa qui dove
vi trovate invece una palma e non vedete
altro perché nella palma dentro la palla
ma ce lo spot anche perché io ho sempre
avuto come linee guida il fatto di
cercare di fare anche delle tecnologia
che fosse un minimo non dico bella da
vedere una tecnologia non è quasi mai
bella vedere ma un minimo bella da
vedere ovviamente mantenendo nella
funzionalità allora faccio una
brevissima digressione mi piace farla
proprio questa cosa che a me non è mai
piaciuto cioè della tecnologia invasiva
io
faccio sempre vedere questa foto quella
è una stazione radio base per telefonia
mobile montata al centro di una vigna un
obrobrio noi nel nostro laboratorio
cerchiamo invece di sviluppare un tipo
di tecnologia
questo è una nostra telecamera per il
monitoraggio dei parassiti in una vigna
che fondamentalmente delle prestazioni
ma direi allineate a quelle di quel
grafico del più fortunato di averlo
savoia che vi ho fatto vedere prima ma
notate la dimensione della moneta da 50
centesimi di euro
ecco quella telecamera è poco più grande
allora li questo lavoro che stiamo
facendo con questi oggetti serve proprio
e ci tenevo a farvi vedere questa cosa a
favore della tecnologia applicata alla
sostenibilità con queste microcamere che
costano anche molto poco noi riusciamo a
diminuire l'utilizzo della chimica in
agricoltura
ma non è questo l'oggetto della della
presentazione per cui ovviamente non mi
dilungherò ma vi assicuro che andare ad
operare in quei panorami a barbaresco in
piemonte a montalcino in toscana ne
sapete qualcosa perché è vicino a qui è
una soddisfazione ovviamente impagabile
però veniamo alla parte finale nel 2014
a giugno del 2014
lui giugno del 2014 avevamo la
consapevolezza che il nostro bel
progetto il nostro bel esperimento di
verrua savoia stava finendo quello che
avete il mio orto ci sono una serie di
pomodori un grande numero
semplicemente perché io essendo un
pessimo gestore di ortone metto il
triplo per raccogliere nella metà questa
è l'idea ma in ogni caso ovviamente
questo mi dà un po di lavoro però e per
cui mentre zappa vim i pomodori mi venne
in mente che forse riuscivamo a
trasformare quello che averla savoia fu
per quattro anni un esperimento tecnico
in un esperimento sociale e proprio
utilizzando quella caratteristica che vi
ho raccontato prima che aveva generato
un grandissimo consenso e partecipazione
da parte di tutti i cittadini del mio
comune e in che cosa consiste questa
cosa fondamentalmente noi avevamo un
dato avevamo 260 famiglie già collegate
e quella banda che vedete ok non quella
quei 13 più 13 megabit che mediamente
davamo tutte le famiglie a me prelevate
a monte per motivi statistici in nei
quali non voglio entrare aveva in realtà
un costo estremamente ridotto perché le
somme dei 260 utenti non erano pari a
tante volte e quanti gli utenti quella
banda limerà molto meno allora
realizzando un business plan
andammo a vedere quale poteva essere il
costo di gestione di una potenziale
associazione di promozione sociale che
avesse preso in carico quella rete si
fosse registrata come operatore di
comunicazione e come soggetto
rappresentante dei cittadini di quel
comune fosse diventato quella stessa
associazione
il soggetto che gestiva quella rete e
dove fondamentalmente i membri
dell'associazione che diventavano si
utenti della rete ma anche proprietaria
della rete stessa
avrebbero erogato il servizio pubblico a
se stessi ebbene facendo quelle
proiezioni
ne risultò che se delle mie 260 famiglie
avessero aderito in 180 avrei fatto
pagare loro 80 euro all'anno
80 euro all'anno per dare 13 megabit
bidirezionali nel comune di averlo e
savoia dove nessuno voleva andare a
portare la banda larga dove attualmente
a casa mia
il telefono cellulare non prende e vi
assicuro che per me questa è una
grandissima cosa però detto questo nasce
l'associazione i miei concittadini ci
credono
la chiamiamo senza fili senza confini
per ovvi motivi era basata sull'utilizzo
di apparecchiature radio quindi c'era un
filo conduttore è quello che succede è
che la mia aspettativa minima di
riuscita che era basata sul fatto da 260
di diventare 180 bene diventammo subito
250 poi ne recuperammo altri sette ora
di quei 260 ne abbiamo 257 ma siamo
diventati 330
paradossalmente però savoia preferiscono
quando si paga rispetto a quando non si
paga ma non entriamo in questo dettaglio
anche perché di nuovo
raccontarvela un po però ecco in realtà
questa è quello che è successo ed in
questo momento quell'associazione lavora
questo è una cosa che mi piace far
vedere nella aprile 2015 abbiamo fatto
la nostra assemblea generale che
facciamo ogni anche faremo ogni anno
ebbene dei 330 soci 291 parteciparono
all'assemblea 291 provate a fare
un'assemblea di condominio a fare anche
un'assemblea che deve discutere cose
economiche importanti a riunire più del
90 per cento degli dei condomini questo
è quello che fa adesso l'associazione
fare corsi per coinvolgere gli anziani
insieme con i bambini per educare quella
fetta di popolazione che ancora il
divario digitale ma non e
infrastrutturale non economico culturale
per imparare ad accedere a internet
tutto fatto per tramite di volontari e
vi saluto con questa che il panorama che
io vedevo dal monte rosa
quella sera in cui tutti quegli altri
navigavano grazie